that's insane literally insane you have
to be a crazy person to believe this
what in the actual f is he talking about
charles blow i'm sure sipping his latte
spoiling for some sort of ideological
civil war here this is radical horse
crap
most americans don't like this critical
race theory stuff they don't like it and
they don't like it because it's bad
because it's ugly and because it's
untrue when i say it's bad it's ugly and
it's untrue let me just give you an
example
of the kind of opinions it leads you to
so charles blow who's an awful columnist
for the new york times but at least
give him the merit of he says what's on
his mind he doesn't hide the ball he has
a piece in the new york times today it
is titled is america a racist country
he gets to the good part about halfway
down in the piece
he says abraham lincoln said during his
famous debates about against stephen
douglas in 1858 that among white people
in black ones quote there must be the
position of superior and inferior and i
as much as any other man i'm in favor of
the superior position being assigned to
the white man
which is an actual quote from abraham
lincoln in 1858 you know
when he was arguing against slavery
and was transitioning away from the
racism that was inherent in american
society
here but listen to where listen to where
charles blow a black columnist for the
most prestigious newspaper in america
the new york times goes with this you
ready
someone can see the historical point and
insist on the progress point
arguing that was then and this is now
that racism simply doesn't exist now as
it then then
i would agree american racism has
evolved and become less blunt
but it has not become less effective the
knife has simply been sharpened
now systems do the work that once
required the overt actions of masses of
individual racists
okay that's that's just madness i mean
this is where critical race theory leads
to absolute utter madness that's insane
to suggest that systems of slavery in
the united states and jim crow in the
united states
are no less effective than the systems
of racism in place today is insane
okay i don't mean that it's unreasonable
i mean it literally insane you have to
be a crazy person to believe this
that racism in america in 2021
is more effective or as effective as
slavery and jim crow racism
you also have to be totally crazy to
suggest as charles blow does
that the knife has been sharpened that
now racism is sharper than it was
right it's gotten more effective more
more efficient than it was
during the days of you know enslavement
of black people and treating them as
chattel property
and or the days in which black americans
were barred from going to the same
schools as white americans
were forced to drink at their own water
fountains were forced to take separate
modes of transportation
and were barred from restaurants like
what in the actual f is he talking about
charles blow i'm sure sipping his latte
at a nice restaurant on the upper west
side of manhattan while writing a piece
for the new york times
and i'm sorry this is crazy and he says
systems do the work that once
required the overt actions of masses of
individual races
so um is he unaware that slavery was a
system
a legalized system is he unaware that
jim crow is a legally mandated
system not not just allowed mandated if
you go back to read
alabama jim crow laws it was not
restaurants may segregate if they wish
to
restaurants must segregate whether or
not they wish to
it was a state mandate and now he's
saying that
in america in which racism
discrimination has been federally
outlawed
since 1965 for night on 50 years
right you're talking over 50 years 55
years since the civil rights act
you're talking here about how america
is more racist or just as racist as it
was then
because its systems are so intertwined
with racism you know the same systems
that have legally barred racism
okay this is a perverse worldview it's a
disgusting a lying worldview when i talk
about dishonesty and misinformation
this is utter dishonesty it is
misinformation it is a lie
it is a gigantic lie and is being
promoted day in
and day out by your members of the
establishment media who are spoiling for
some sort of ideological civil war here
this is radical horse crap okay and they
are they're promoting it
every single day how are they promoting
it okay so this came up for a vote
okay so in south lake texas they're a
bunch of candidates
and they opposed a local school
diversity plan okay the local school
diversity plan which is an orwellian
name
for a school education plan that was
going to use all these garbage critical
race theory points
there's the school board election the
school board was taken over
70 by 70 30 vote that is not a close
vote 70 30 is a blowout by any standard
a castro like blowout by a 70 30 vote
the school board that was promoting the
critical race theory garbage was tossed
out
and instead people were put in place who
believed in teaching traditional
american history with all of its warts
and all of its flaws
here is how this election remember 70
30 70 30 was
characterized by nbc news again your
establishment media they say that the
right wants the civil war no no no the
right is just sitting here
we just want to be left alone we want to
be able to teach our kids traditional
american history
you guys are the ones who apparently
want the ideological and maybe more than
that civil war
i can't find any other explanation
here's how nbc news headlined this
remember i keep emphasizing 70 30
election because the headline about i'm
about to read is delusional
quote opponents of anti-racism education
so first of all they're already using
the sort of language that is promoted by
the critical race theorists right and
when they promote overt racism
as in white americans are inherently
part of systems of racism
and they have to inc they have to wallow
in supposed systemic and institutional
white guilt
they call themselves anti-racist
educators they are racist ever max
kennedy has suggested
that discrimination today is the
solution to discrimination of the past
he's a racist
okay but this is anti-racism now send me
nbc news headlines this
opponents of anti-racism education win
big
in a bitterly divided election in south
lake texas conservative candidates who
opposed a school diversity plan won
every local race
taking about 70 percent of the vote in
the wealthy dallas fort worth suburb
so i have a question bitterly divided
election
by what standard is a 7030 blowout a
bitterly divided election
that's not a bitterly divided election
can you imagine if republicans had lost
that race
it would be in stunning rebuke of
traditional american thought
the radical new magical people
who promote critical race theory win big
right it would be a blowout
the media's headline would have been
blow out 70 30 is a blowout it is not a
bitterly divided election but the
headline is a bitterly divided election
on one side says nbc news progressives
argue that curriculum and disciplinary
changes were needed
to make all children feel safe and
welcome and carol a mostly white but
quickly diversifying school district
on the other conservatives in south lake
rejected the school diversity plan
as an effort to indoctrinate students
with a far-left ideology that according
to some when institutionalized
discrimination
against white children and those with
conservative christian values
candidates and voters on both sides
described the election as a fork in the
road for south lake
in the end the contest was not close yes
so then why was it bitterly divided it
wasn't
okay they got blown out as well they
should have been
but the media have an interest in
promoting the idea that we are bitterly
divided over the stuff
even though we are not it is the reason
why the media hate tim scott so much
hate him the senator from south carolina
because tim scott correctly points out
the critical race theory is not only
mumbo jumbo it is garbage it is racism
this is why you end up with msnbc's
tiffany cross calling calling tim scott
a sitting united states senator from
south carolina a token and a clown
and sure tim scott has spoken out about
his encounters with law enforcement and
he
co-sponsored the anti-lynching bill in
the senate
but there are two sides to every token
so
thirsty for white approval this dude
actually stood on the
national stage to defend the voter
suppression law in georgia
please senator say more about how
unracist the country is
while you trot out that tired line about
going from cotton
to congress to clown it's a clowns he's
a clown
he's a token and he's a racist tim scott
these are the folks
who are ginning up civil war in the
country the folks of the radical left in
the establishment media these are the
folks who lie to every day about the
nature of the country
and they're taking over the institutions
on virtually every front
i mean obviously you have radicals like
maxine waters who've been saying this
sort of stuff for years here's maxine
waters saying that every single day
we've seen this nation get more racist
every single day really really maxine
waters every day in america we get more
racist
weird because i've noticed some
differences between 2021 and say 1861.
namely that you're sitting in congress
saying absolute horse crap
for the giggles and hoots of the media
it's insane
every day we have seen you know this
nation
get more racist uh than anybody thought
perhaps
would be at this point in time we've
been through the civil rights movement
where of course we made some progress
but this uh president that we had trump
was taking us backwards uh and he was
making racist comments
uh he was um you know identifying
himself
with people like the ku klux klan and
the proud boys
and the oath keepers and the uh q anon
i mean that is racism defined
uh in the most uh obvious way okay
racism to define the most obvious way
would be
active discrimination on the basis of
race maxine waters is an open promoter
of that sort of ideology it just depends
on the race
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment